I'm hearing that there was a moment
where you know the the job world for you
got a little tough uh and you were you
were like a Spider-Man and at kids
parties for a little bit yeah right yeah
you were doing Spider-Man work showing
up at the parties being Spider-Man for
sure yeah 75 bucks an hour kids [ __ ]
what you doing right yeah uh at the time
a Marvel fan or not uh yeah yeah yeah
big big superhero I mean I mean you know
my my vision board in the very beginning
of like imaginary vision board but my my
goal at the very beginning was like Oh I
wanna I would love to be a superhero one
okay that was the I didn't think it
would I mean not like that but um that
was a way to uh because I had gotten
laid off from the job I'd also made the
decision to like give this acting thing
a go but yeah I just didn't have the
capital so what's the word of the Tweet
like there's a there's a tweet that
exists yeah you kind of of
foreshadowing the world of you being in
Marvel right and is this real or is it
no it's real it's real it's real I
remember you know at one point I think
it was like 20 2014 or 2015 I tweeted uh
I tweeted like hey Marvel great great
job with uh you know Captain America and
Thor two two white guys
um how about an Asian superhero how
about an Asian American superhero it's
actually what I said [ __ ] around yeah
[ __ ] around nobody ever no and nobody
ever saw it I forgot about it and then
you know yeah fast forward uh fast
forward five years and and um you know I
get cast I get marched out in front of
Comic-Con and then somebody is like do
you remember that you tweeted this song
that's not a little surreal to you it's
crazy yeah the power of like
manifestation yeah of just saying
something yeah and then and then
becoming the guy yeah becoming the guy
what's the feeling of conversation with
being a guy who's the first to become
yeah the first ever oh my God the first
ever to cover a magazine the first to
step on the stage and take the truck
like what is that now it is honestly so
constant that Bowen when I was on SNL in
November we made a skip making fun of it
where we just started being like first
person to ride a [ __ ] Dragon first
person to play you know like we just
started throwing it around because it is
it happens all the time and it's not the
first time I found myself in that
conversation because before I did the
Marvel thing I was on a I was on a
sitcom called Kim's Convenience we did
we did comedy for like five years and um
at the time too that was like the
groundbreaking thing with the you know
an all-asian cast and barriers were
being broken and all that and um I think
it's easy to get cynical when when this
stuff happens and you're answering these
questions for like the 500th time and
all that but but I just I think back to
you know when I was first starting out
the world that I believed was available
to me right I was an extra and I would
look at the the only other Asian guys
that I saw were the stunt guys and
because those are the only ones that
could really have a future because if
you were an Asian actor and you didn't
know martial arts well then how you're
playing you're playing geek number three
you're playing a at best at best a best
friend of some main character you know
it was unfathomable that we could
actually have a story
that was that was about being Asian in a
place like America or Canada it just
wasn't even on the on the you know on
the horizon so when I first got in I was
you know I I didn't
I mean I didn't actually think I was
going to be a superhero I just thought
oh maybe I just [ __ ] around and maybe
I'd be a stunt man or something but I
would I would just be happy as long as
there's a camera around and we're on a
set and so now as we're now seeing major
progress we're seeing major progress and
we're not only talking about being the
stars of these crazy box office uh
vehicles but we're talking about being
the master of that Narrative of not just
being a face in front of a screen that's
you know you know I'm a huge Jackie Chan
fan massive Jet Li fan like those are
the guys that I watch growing up right
but when you look at those moves the
rush hours and the Shanghai noons and
the you know in the Cradle to the Grave
which I loved by the way it was Jet Li
and DMX so until this day I still don't
understand it it's the it's the best
casting it's the worst best casting I've
ever seen that's that's the best way to
describe it but I mean those were movies
that were dreamed up
um by non-asian people yeah and they and
they put Jackie and they put jet in that
movie be to be the Foreigner to be the
other guy that didn't speak English that
would come in and maybe provide comic
relief or just be the guy that didn't
understand or didn't speak the language
and there's something different there's
something shifting now absolutely first
of all you know we have Asian American
filmmakers that can speak to a this
specifically the type of upbringing that
I had or the life the life that I led
you know all of the things that come
with that whether it's the parental
pressure or you know the idea of like
being agent in a society that doesn't
believe that Asian people are a part of
it you know stuff like that well I think
it's more I think more now what we're
realizing today is that there's a want
for the real side of information right
like there's a want for the real side of
Heritage for the real understanding of
family and value within it there's a
real one right because we lived off of
The Stereotype we lived off of the
hypothetical we live off of what we
thought we knew for so long and we've
made premises movies TV based off of
that but I feel like now there's a one
needed desire for the truth
[Music]